We'll cast your mind back to February last year...
…and you may remember the excitement,...
…when NASA successfully landed its Perseverance Rover on Mars.
Well, it's been busy for the last 15 months or so doing plenty of roving.
And now it's ready for the most important part of the mission,...
…searching for signs of life.
Our science editor, Rebecca Morale, has the details.
The parachute has deployed and we are seeing significant deceleration.
It's a mission that began with a jaw-dropping descent,...
…beaming back real footage of a Mars landing,...
...as NASA's Perseverance Rover was lowered onto the Martian surface.
Over the last year, it's revealed the planet as never seen before,...
…taking some selfies along the way.
It's been busy trundling across the dusty terrain.
And it's made history by flying a helicopter,...
…the first powered flight on another planet.
Now, Perseverance is ready to begin the most important part of its mission,...
…hunting for signs of life.
And it's reached an area where it has the best chance of finding it.
I have been staring at this delta for years now,...
…mostly in orbiter images,...
…and now we're finally right in front of it, seeing it,...
...through the eyes of the rover.
We know there was once liquid water on the surface of Mars.
We know there are organics on the surface of Mars,...
…and so all signs point to the surface of Mars,...
…three and a half to four billion years ago,...
…being a habitable planet.